Congratulations, you just engaged in mental rotation. This is the process of
imagining an object rotating in three-dimensional space. As it turns out,
there's actually some gender differences in performing mental rotation tasks.
It appears that boys and man, perform better in these tasks. This appears to be
universal, because they found similar findings in China, Japan, Ecuador,
Ireland and in the US. So how do we organize information in our environment?
Well we do so by labeling and naming things. We first do this in the most basic
unit of knowledge, which is called a concept. The concept is a mental group of
events, objects, or people. So, for example, the concept of an animal can
include mental groups for birds and fish. And these can be broken down even
further into different types of birds. For example, an eagle or sparrow. In
different types of fish for example a catfish or a koi fish. These concepts
help us in our attempt to organize and perceive the world. To that end we often
engage in what's called a concept hierarchy, as you see here which is an
arrangement of concepts in a particular way. Some being really general, and
some being more specific. And there's two last definitions we need to address
here. The first is category. A category is when multiple concepts are organized
around one concept that they all have in common. For example, vehicles or
trees. We can have all the different types of vehicles or all the different
types of trees organized around this category. And these are well defined, but
other categories can be kind of fuzzy. Such as good or consciousness. It can be
difficult to order other concepts around one of these 2 concepts. And finally
we have a prototype, which is the best fitting example of a category.